[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pause pour ce nouveau
cette fuite sport le magazine consacré
comme vous le savez à l'actualité
sportive du département
c'est parti pour le sommaire jo-2000 24
paris a officiellement été désignée par
le cio pour recevoir les jeux olympiques
dans sept ans une nouvelle historique
accueille avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
dans les yvelines et notamment au
vélodrome nationale ils étaient plus de
500 supporters a vibré devant les écrans
géants installés pour l'occasion
vous entendrez également dans ce
magazine les réactions des sportifs sur
cette annonce
rugby le promu plaisir débute par une
défaite contre bobigny en fédérale 2 les
plaisirs oies se sont inclinés 47 à 17
plus de détails à venir dans quelques
instants
course à pied le paris versailles fêtera
ce dimanche 24 septembre son quarantième
anniversaire plus de 25000 courageux
devrait s'élancer depuis la tour eiffel
pour le parler de cet événement nous
recevrons emmanuel fait hier le
directeur de la course
on commence tout de suite par
l'actualité sportive de la semaine dans
le département
[Musique]
le verdict est tombé aux alentours de 20
heures ce mercredi 13 septembre la ville
de paris fortement pressenti depuis cet
été pour accueillir les jeux olympiques
c'est officiellement vu attribué les jo
de 2024 par le cio pour fêter cette
journée historique saint quentin en
yvelines avait programmée des activités
dans l'enceinte jusqu'à l'annoncent à 20
heures
l'enceinte de ce syndrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines retour sur
l'événement les images sont signés
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Applaudissements]
l'effervescence des jeux olympiques a
frappé le vélodrome nationale ce
mercredi 13 septembre pour le vivre
pleinement la mousse officiel du cio
depuis lima saint quentin en yvelines
avait organisé une journée spéciale
dédiée aux valeurs de l'olympisme
parmi les temps forts 850 enfants sont
venus de toute la région pour participer
à une quarantaine d'ateliers sportifs
les scream
on a déjà vu à la télé mais
et pas n'a jamais fait le golf tout ce
que j'ai fait c'est du mini golf c'est
bien parce que y'en a que j'avais fait
je vais découvrir et meynac j'ai déjà
fait mais du coup bah ça va permettre de
m'améliorer
les enfants ont également pu rencontrer
une dizaine de champions français parmi
eux thomas levet ancien golfeur
professionnel
le sportif a animé des mini ateliers sur
le thème du golfe
moi quand je commence j'ai commencé le
sport c'est en rencontrant des champions
parce que tout d'un quotidien as j'ai
rencontré un tel qu'est ce qui fait
qu'un sport tu commençais à petit y
intéresse un petit peu plus si on
regarde les résultats et puis tu dire à
tes parents dit moi papa j'aimerais bien
faire du judo
par exemple j'aimerais bien faire du
golf mais les champions bas ça ça aide
toujours à passer le cap en se disant
tiens je vais le faire le sport j'essaie
j'aime bien et allons-y
en fin de journée après le départ des
enfants plus de 500 supporters
tricolores sont venus assister en direct
à la danse du cio via des écrans géants
installés pour l'occasion
bah oui c'est important ça fait cent ans
que paris attend les jo donc je pense
que c'est important de célébrer tous
ensemble cet événement aujourd'hui être
présent
pour cette première échéance je dirais
de confirmation de gillot oui c'est
important on est acteur tous autant
qu'on est à chaque niveau donc oui après
de longues minutes d'attentes le verdict
tombe enfin paris officiellement
désignée ville hôte pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024 par le sig telle
réaction extraordinaire une réaction de
joie une réaction de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel et là
c'est vraiment une explosion de joie en
a senti lors de l' annonce est
maintenant l aventure commence une
aventure commence c'est une aventure
historique et ça va être passionnant de
vivre cette période
les supporters présents vélodrome
national espère maintenant vibrer dans
un peu moins de 7 ans avec des médailles
d'or françaises
cette victoire c'est également la
victoire des sportifs des centaines
d'athlètes se sont mobilisés pendant les
des mois dans toute la france et
notamment dans les yvelines pour faire
pencher la balance du côté de la
candidature parisienne
il était évidemment tous ravis après l
annonce officielle on les écoute
pour moi c'est un peu sans surprise
parce que vraiment on a mis toutes nos
chances de notre côté voilà c'était
beaucoup reggae sur les réseaux sociaux
et tout donc très contente
salses et ce en tant qu on les a pas
eues c'est taylor d'avoir on n'est pas
passé loin à londres on n'est pas passé
loin avant on approche présenté
plusieurs candidatures de temps en temps
qui étaient pas bonnes d'autres étaient
bonnes et puis à londres ça nous a fait
mal et là on sait on a vraiment mis les
moyens et je pense que la candidature
était la plus belle et c'était normal
que paris et les jeux en 2024
un soulagement un soulagement est en
vente dans l'ensemble de joie satisfait
contente et plaisir après les sportifs
coup de projecteur sur les épreuves qui
seront organisées dans les yvelines
saint quentin en yvelines sera donc à
l'honneur pendant les jo de 2024 quatre
sites ont été retenus par les
organisateurs français les épreuves de
cyclisme sur piste seront programmés
dans le vélodrome nationale la structure
inaugure en 2014 a déjà cuits les
championnats du monde en 2015 et les
championnats d'europe l'année suivante à
une centaine de mètres du vélodrome
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines a été sélectionné dans le
dossier paris 2024 pour accueillir les
épreuves masculines et féminines de bmx
une piste modulable provisoire sera
construite pour l'occasion la colline
d'elancourt qui culmine à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude accueillera quand elle les
épreuves de vtt le projet dans les
cartons depuis les jo de 2012 a été
ressortie pour la candidature de paris
2024 enfin le golf national recevra les
épreuves golfique les joueurs
disputeront les parties sur le parcours
de l'albatros le 18 trous réputé comme
l'un des plus exigeants au monde et qui
a été entièrement rénové entre 2015 et
on écoute palermitaine jeu directeur du
golf national en l'accueillît
extrêmement bien parce qu'on l'a pris
très au sérieux
on a voulu montrer un savoir faire
depuis depuis un nom plus d'un an où il
ya des visites techniques à des visites
développement durable il ya des visites
des sites futur olympique et donc on a
un parc
on ya participé vraiment
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé beaucoup de
réflexion c'est une reconnaissance je
remercie toutes les équipes du golfe et
est évidemment la fédération française
de golf dans le reste des yvelines les
épreuves d'équitation et de pentathlon
moderne se disputeront à versailles les
courses de cyclisme sur route devrait
quant à elle passer dans la vallée de
chevreuse on continue à parler des jo de
2024 dans ce magazine sur le plan
sportif la compétition se prépare à dès
à présent en cyclisme sur piste la
nouvelle génération des pistards à
tricolore est symbolisé par deux jeunes
pétris de talent mathilde de gros 18 ans
et sébastien vigier à 20 ans malgré leur
jeune âge ils ont déjà raflé des
médailles internationales dans ces
derniers mois le montage est signée accv
jamin mathilde de gros 18 ans sébastien
vigier 20 ans deux des plus grands
espoirs du cyclisme sur piste français
en 2017 les deux pépites ont tout raflé
sur leur passage cet été la jeune
sprinteuse a notamment réalisé le triplé
aux championnats de france élite
sébastien lui réussi plusieurs podiums
en coupe du monde une réussite qui ne
surprend pas les coaches de l'équipe de
france ils ont une envie de réussir qui
est vraiment au delà de la moyenne même
du groupe
c'est vraiment quelque chose c'est
vraiment une grande exigence au
quotidien et c'est vrai que une volonté
de réussir en ordre et progresse très
vite et ils atteignent des niveaux tout
cas déjà dans leur catégorie d'âge qui
sont parmi les meilleurs du monde une
progression fulgurante qui pourrait les
emmener à devenir les futurs stars de la
discipline en 2024 lors des jeux
olympiques de paris voit bien sûr j'ai
vraiment envie d'y être c'est un peu on
va dire l'objectif d'une carrière mais
ça serait way bella projet de carrière
de participer au championnat devenant un
pic à paris pour l'instant je pense
plutôt court terme
c'est quand même dans huit ans donc
non j'ai pas encore imaginer ça mais
peut-être bientôt le chemin et n'a fait
que trois ans que je fais du vélo du
coup voilà je sais que voilà j'ai tout
gagné chez les juniors mais je sais que
la marche juniors élite est très très
très très grande et qui est encore pour
être médaillés au jugé encore et man ont
des progrès à faire que ce soit physique
technique tactique mais avant de penser
aux médailles d'or olympiques il faudra
passer encore de nombreuses heures à
s'entraîner sur la piste du vélotour
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il ya des étapes à franchir
il ya des formations affaires et les
résultats viendront avec le temps et
voilà tout et tout est planifié sur sur
une voire deux olympiades pour qu'ils
puissent être performant la prochaine
étape pour les deux pépites françaises
les championnats d'europe élite
programmée du 18 au 22 octobre à berlin
un rendez-vous mathilde et sébastien
espère briller elle a quelques années de
plus que mathilde de gros et sébastien
vie j'ai un peu moins d'un an après
l'incroyable record de robert marchand
105 ans sur la piste du vélotour
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
autre seigneur va tenter de repousser
les limites du corps humain dans
l'enceinte sportive
genette augusto 82 ans originaire de
vesoul se lancera sur la piste pour
établir un record du monde de l'heure
féminin des plus de 80 ans la sportive
portera pour l'occasion le maillot de
leusse et à vélizy 78 devant le public
47 ans après avoir réalisé pour le club
le record de france sur piste du 500 m
départ arrêté est forcément à l'émotion
est présente jeannette était au micro de
tv 78 il faut pas trop en parler parce
qu'elle est ce assez de lait bottieau ah
ouais quand on a apporté des gens qui
prend un club
et puis qu'on remet ça c'est quand même
quelque chose et puis certainement
tellement bien l'entourer c'est
important aussi
jeannette espère réaliser une moyenne de
28 km heure pendant son record pour cela
elle s'entraîne tous les deux jours en
réalisant des séances de 45 à 50 km on
continue de parler du club de vélizy 78
les masters sont brillé la semaine
dernière dernière sur le vélodrome de
roubaix pendant les championnats
d'europe sur piste
les sportifs sont repartis dans leurs
valises avec trois titres cinq médailles
d'argent et deux médailles de bronze
il ya du jard ya notamment remporté la
médaille d'or sur l'épreuve de vitesse
individuelle en devançant son coéquipier
sébastien terry l'elysée ont également
conquis le titre en vitesse par équipes
prochaine étape les championnats du
monde qui se tiendront à los angeles du
8 au 15 octobre
on ouvre à présent une page handball en
nationale 2 féminine montigny le
bretonneux a plutôt réussi sa rentrée à
ce week-end les y montaient non
neutraliser le paris saint germain à
l'extérieur laisse le score 23 a partout
pour parler de cette compte cette
performance des objectifs du club cette
saison nous recevons sur ce plateau le
président christophe reding le coach
cholet est la capitaine clémence
campagne bonsoir bonsoir alors donischal
et est ce que c'est une belle
performance tout à fait ou une nulle
contre paris saint germain
absolument parce que déjà l'année
dernière paris saint germain nous avait
posé énormément de problèmes
il était dans notre poule également
cette année on a un petit peu remis
comme on dit les pendules à l'heure
c'est un premier match tout n'est pas
parfait je pense que quelqu'un pourra en
reparler un peu plus mais par contre des
choses très intéressantes parce que le
groupe a été un petit peu modifié par
rapport à l'an dernier mais les
nouvelles joueuses qui arrivent
s'intègre énormément fait très bien et
ce sont des joueuses d'expérimenter donc
qui apporte énormément aussi et on a un
peu surpris pg à ce niveau là c'est bon
ça ce qu'on peut revenir sur ce match
contre le paris saint-germain
c'est une équipe qui nous avait battus
deux fois la saison passée cette fois-ci
vous commencez à l'extérieur par un nul
est ce que le groupe a grandi a mûri oui
je pense que c'est pour moi c'est une
très bonne performance qu'on a fait ce
week-end en effet on restait sur deux
défaites contre le paris saint-germain
donc on arrivait quand même à paris avec
un bon esprit de revanche avec un groupe
modifié qui avait pas vécu ce qu'on
avait vécu l'année dernière et un vent
de fraîcheur et je pense qu'on les a
bien surpris surprise pardon mais non
s'annonce très bien la saison en tout
cas moi je suis très contente du groupe
de ce qu'on a fait très bon esprit sur
cette rencontre et on s est un présage
de bonnes choses pour le reste de la
saison président est ce que c'est un
résultat logique au logiciel contre le
paris saint-germain en tout cas
hu à comprendre que oui finalement oui
oui la préparation s'est faite au vu des
résultats de l'année précédente
et vous avez face à vous un président
qui est content parce qu en fait
l'objectif fixé à cette équipe et à son
entraîneur
comme je vous l'avais déjà précisé
l'année dernière c'est un objectif qui
se porte sur deux ans c'est une montée
donc l'armée dans la deuxième année sur
la deuxième année donc avec l'objectif
d'accéder à la nationale 1 l'année
prochaine et de bénéficier en fait du
des modifications des poules qui va
intervenir les prochaines sur haut
niveau au niveau fédéral c'est à dire
qu'en fait on va passer de 2 poule de n1
à quatre poules donc pour nous l'idée
c'est d'être dans les cinq dans les cinq
meilleurs de nationale 2 groupe cette
année
pour pouvoir bénéficier de cette
accession et poursuivre les objectifs du
club
c'est la formation des jeunes idy mon
teint et des jeunes de saint quentin en
yvelines au handball et au haut niveau
du handball
concernant les jeunes les jeunes filles
et grâce en fait à 7 à cette équipe
phare féminine ça donnera envie à ces
jeunes filles de poursuivre donc là
aujourd'hui oui vous avez un président
qui est content denys choulet
l'année dernière ça n'avait pas très
bien commencé pour
montigny-le-bretonneux vous pointiez à
une inquiétante avant dernière place
devant la dernière même au mois de
novembre cette année finalement vous
allez tenter de rectifier le tir je
suppose tout à fait oui mais ce que les
intensités sur les premiers matchs
absolument pour engranger un maximum
déjà par rapport à l'année dernière il
ya eu les dernières pour faire un petit
historique
il y avait vraiment et dans le monde
changements parce que neuf joueuses
étaient partis on repartait sur un
groupe tout neuf
donc il a fallu gérer recréer un petit
peu cette cette équipe et cet état
d'esprit que l'on recherche
cette année je
suis reposé un petit peu sur l'effectif
dernier dernier en incorporant quelques
joueuses d'expérience mais le l'ossature
et l ossature de l'année dernière donc
c'est pour ça que déjà le travail le
travail technique est déjà bien bien
élaboré maintenant il faut j'ai dit
raffiner ses petites ce petit rodage que
l'on a au niveau on a encore un peu de
pertes de balle pour des
incompréhensions mais ça je pense que ça
va aller assez vite dans le donjon
clémence à une dernière le président le
disait c'était une saison de transition
cette année c'est vraiment la saison de
la confirmation vous en parlait
peut-être entre vous entre chose on n'en
parle pas encore vraiment je pense qu'on
est concentrée la course terme sur match
après match on a vraiment à coeur de
bien commencer cette saison justement
pour pas réitérer ce qui s'est passé
l'année dernière on s'est mis dans le
rouge dès le départ et où la fin de
saison était très compliqué je pense que
là pendant pour juste à engranger le
maximum de points et on parlera de la
montée quand il sera l'heure d'en parler
pendant se concentre sur les matches à
venir et je pense que c'est déjà pas mal
présidant la montée c'est obligatoire
cette année
clairement oui clairement oui mettez la
pression je mets la pression aulas
l'entraîneur et aux joueuses
cependant je reste quand même mesuré
dans tout ce que je peux dire il faut
aussi que derrière le club puisse
assumer une montée en n1 et y rester
c'est à dire que par rapport à cela il
est clair le club a aussi besoin
d'être aidés pour pouvoir s'y maintenir
c'est à dire qu on est constamment à la
recherche de partenaires est en fête et
de bonne volonté
or il n'y a pas forcément que des
histoires financière qui rend le jeu
d'une dispense de haut niveau on a
également besoin de bénévolat on a
besoin de gens qui viennent avec nous au
moment des matches qui viennent
supporter les joueuses mais on a aussi
besoin de gens qui viennent nous donner
des petits coups de main pour tenir une
buvette pour être sur un club de
supporters c'est ça qu'on a réellement
besoin
si aujourd'hui saint quentin en yvelines
voeux à une équipe professionnelle de
handball a sera obligé de passer par là
donc par le biais d'une chaîne comme
téléphiles 78 qui est une chaîne locale
c'est quelque chose qui pourra toucher
les saint quentinois et c'est grâce à
cela qu'on y arrivera on va continuer à
vous suivre en tout cas merci à tous les
trois dépassé à sur ce plateau pour
répondre à nos questions le prochain
match programmé ce samedi à 20h30 à
domicile au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin contre hazebrouck du ballon
d'or le ballon passe au ballon ovale
coup de projecteur aujourd'hui sur le
club de plaisir les plaisirs wa promu
cette saison en fédérale 2 vont tenter
de se maintenir face à des équipes mieux
armées sportivement et économiquement
tour d'horizon de l'équipe senior avec
notre journaliste nicolas d'henri 28 mai
2010 cette phase finale de fédérale 3 à
oussouye plaisir ça sur la montée en
division supérieure
[Musique]
après les festivités
retour sur les terrains les seniors du
plaisir rugby club préparent leur saison
en fédérale 2 une préparation menée par
deux nouveaux entraîneurs sébastien
roncalli et nicolas lafon objectif pour
le promu le maintien on verra comment ça
se passera on se met pas de barrières en
tout cas on est on a une philosophie de
mettre un maximum de volume de jeu en
place donc voilà on jouera en jour à
100% tous les coups et on verra après
par la suite si on peut espérer autre
chose c'est un gros challenge évidemment
surtout quand on voit la qualité de des
équipes de la poule
maintenant le groupe a connu deux
montées
donc il a quand même une bonne dynamique
une bonne dynamique sur laquelle le
collectif peut se reposer
peu de mouvements au sein du groupe la
continuité règne au sein de l'équipe
seuls quelques changements sur le
contenu des entraînements et la
philosophie du jeu
on met beaucoup d'intensité dans un
entraînement on a rajouté quelques
séances et les maxi colle vraiment donc
tout le groupe dans l'ensemble est
motivé pour faire le mieux possible
donc on est vraiment sur ce travail là
sur du mouvement général est vraiment
renforcer les repères des joueurs quoi
sur les jeux de relance ou tout ce qui
est stratégie voilà renforcer vraiment à
la stratégie au niveau du nul de
l'équipe
la touche roncalli la faune pour mettre
en harmonie le jeu du prc une partition
que devront suivre les joueurs pour
espérer le maintien en fédérale 2 le
club de plaisir jouer justement ce week
ce week-end son premier match de
championnat de fédérale 2 deux ans après
avoir quitté cette division et plaisir
oies se sont lourdement inclinés à 47 à
17 contre bobigny
retour sur la rencontre les images sont
signés à nicolas nourrit pour son retour
en fédérale 2 plaisir qu'ils aient voulu
en jaune et bleu avec une partie
compliquée contre bobigny sous dimanche
17 septembre les plaisirs oies se sont
inclinés sur leur pelouse 47 à 17 en
encaissant un terrible 44 en première
période
c'est une équipe qui a beaucoup de plus
d'expérience que nous
au niveau je rappelle qu'il est en
fédérale 2 l'année dernière quand même
et
et c'est vrai que dès qu'on se consommer
un petit peu trop sur les phases de ruck
où six a raté un placage bois tout de
suite ça faisait la différence ça jouer
dans le dos parce qu'on n'était pas
forcément capable de faire
collectivement on était on était pas mal
en place malheureusement
individuellement on a fait vraiment des
grosses fautes de défense
et puis bah face à une très belle équipe
comme ça avec les joueurs rapides qu'ils
avaient forcément on a pris beaucoup
d'essais donc là la mi-temps ça faisait
cher quand même
de retour des vestiaires le père serre
montrer un autre visage devant son
public les plaisirs ont marqué deux
essais en 40 minutes contre un dc pour
bobigny on vient de la deuxième mi-temps
alors après ce que
on mais c'est un petit peu le rythme ce
qu'ils ont fait tourner au jeu c'est pas
tout cas on essaie de montrer un peu
plus fière allure et
l'ombre du coup ça a payé il faut sans
s'accrocher à ce à quoi il faudra
s'inspirer de cette seconde période dès
dimanche prochain plaisir se déplacera
sur le terrain de drancy une équipe qui
avait engrangé une victoire dans ce
championnat de fédérale 2 avant de
passer à notre page agenda coup de
projecteur sur un résultat du week-end
en baseball les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux jouer ce week-end leur
demi-finale retour sur le terrain de
rouen une série qui se joue au meilleur
des cinq matchs en mauvaise posture
après avoir perdu les deux premières
rencontres 6 à 2 et 10 à 3 la semaine
dernière les il monte un se sont
inclinés donc dans le troisième
rendez-vous 9 à 3 résultat qui permet à
rouen de remporter la série à 3 à 0
les cougars promu cette saison sont donc
éliminés au stade des demi finales
l'un des meilleurs résultats de
l'histoire du club on passe maintenant à
notre rubrique agenda
[Musique]
on commence à ta gens d'à part de la
course à pied la 40e édition du paris
versailles est programmée ce dimanche
entre la tour eiffel et l'avenue de
paris à versailles
on attend près de 25000 à courageux à
l'arrivée pour nous parler de cet
événement nous sommes avec en plateau
avec emmanuel fait hier le coordinateur
de la course bonsoir bonsoir
alors je disais 40 ans cette édition
s'annonce historique historique par
forcément les chiffres le chiffre
historique par l'engouement puisque nous
avons clôture des inscriptions le 10
juin dernier et nous souhaitons limiter
les inscriptions à 25 mille coureurs
pour garantir un niveau de satisfaction
pour tous ceux qui viennent nous
rejoindre de la tour eiffel jusqu'au
parcours mythique avec la cote des gares
la côte du cimetière à viroflay
et forcément l'avenue de paris à
versailles et puis
certes c'est mythique cette année mais
on souhaiterait que ça dure on encore
très longtemps pour pouvoir fêter
ensemble avec tv fil 78 la 50e édition
de paris versailles
on sera évidemment sur place il ya aussi
une valeur symbolique aussi avec les
jeux olympiques qui seront organisés à
paris joliment et à versailles
ça apporte une dimension supplémentaire
à l'événement cette année une dimension
sade et raconte une vraie histoire le
lien entre paris les yvelines versailles
franchement le l'histoire est très belle
et puis avec l'actualité qui est récente
y'a pas mieux et on est très ravi que la
candidature ait pu être sélectionné par
le comité olympique
alors comment fait-on niveau logistique
pour organiser un tel événement je le
disais précédemment 25 mille coureurs
comment fait on se prépare un an la
vence c'est plus que ça en suisse que
tard c'est moi j'ai l'habitude de dire
on fait une double grossesse ses 18 ans
de préparation
les premiers contacts on les a avec par
exemple la sncf pour réserver des
sillons donc on réserve les trains les
horaires de train dix-huit mois al
avance donc là déjà la date du 30
septembre 2018 est fixé était transmise
à la sncf 2010-2019 également et puis
ensuite à partir du mois de novembre
on commence à travailler sur la
stratégie de l'événement aspects
budgétaires
ensuite on commence à affiner tout les
tous les dossiers et des bus début
février mi février ont lancé les
inscriptions et quelques mois plus tard
donc en à peine six mois tout et tout et
clôt donc là c'est une vraie une vraie
une vraie réussite un vrai succès
surtout que toutes les courses ne sont
pas sur le même ce même profil que nous
et puis ensuite on rentre dans la partie
opérationnelle
on est aujourd'hui dans la partie
opérationnelle avec la réception de pas
mal de marchandise et tout sera prêt
pour dimanche à 10 heures au pied la
tour eiffel et quels sont les conseils
que vous donneriez aux coureurs qui vont
s'élancer a beau aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui clairement faut faire du jus
faux faux pas les couvrir de la semaine
il faut au contraire est bien bio se
reposer bien s'hydrater et puis ensuite
prendre du plaisir on n'est pas sur une
compétition comme on peut le voir sur
des marathons ou des 10 km chronométrés
qualificatif rischmann france on est là
pour se faire plaisir pour passer un
super bon moment et on voit beaucoup
d'entreprises ou des amis
qui profite de l'événement pour venir
ensemble et participer à l'événement et
c'est ça le l'adn du paris versailles
c'est venir entre amis entre copains
entre collègues et passé un super bon
moment et le temps limite c'est pas
grave c'est plutôt l'ambiance et du
plaisir d'un art question au niveau
sportif
aucun français n'a remporté la
compétition depuis 2010 oui est ce que
cette année il y aura un français
vainqueur à versailles va peut-être ça
va pour la réac sur la ligne d'arrivée
pour l'observer pour le voir mais en
même temps c'est vrai que vous avez les
les athlètes des hauts plateaux qui sont
souvent présents cette année on a
souhaité réduire un peu la présence du
d'état qui a été dit pour favoriser les
athlètes entre guillemets populaire et
c'est pas forcément notre notre priorité
la priorité c'est les vingt-cinq mille
coureurs clairement est notre credo
c'est le service aux coureurs le service
aux coureurs le service aux coureurs
merci à vous d'être passés ces bateaux
on vous souhaite bon courage
d'intermédiation j'imagine que la
dernière ligne droite on aura acharné
vous n'avez pas dû travailler encore
vous avez encore du travail
merci à vous ici c'est la fin de ce
statut de sport déjà rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
10 il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]